davos leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem kurzen video
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich
warum macht der trailer videos der band
krank ist nicht krank aber ich habe
heute einen brutalen unitag ich habe 14
losgelegt es ist jetzt 13 uhr öffnen ich
habe zehn losgelegt in der uni und hat
noch bis 9 uhr
juni also rächen märchen elf stunden so
und elf stunden ja deshalb bisschen
scheiße an als bisschen stress messi
wisst bescheid und deswegen kann ich
halt kein video aufnehmen weil ich nicht
so bockhop allein zocken und jetzt um
die uhrzeit ich hab gerade kurze
mittagspause von 12 30 bis 13 30 die
uhrzeit ist noch keine online war nahmen
noch und schon setzen ein cluster die
treffen und kann aber nämlich auch dann
könnten deswegen denke ich mir so juni
live video und ja es gibt auch noch aus
anzukündigen und zwar mit man dass sich
vielleicht diese tage endlich bei einem
netzwerk unterkommen könnte es ist noch
nicht alles in trockenen tüchern aber
ich bin ich in gesprächen oder so aber
ich hätte richtig bock zu diesem anlass
faktoren darstellen
und ja es könnte sein dass es zustande
kommt ist natürlich mega geil aber noch
besseren antworten kamen von mein leben
hier bist du da und oben und einfach ein
bisschen noch bessere videos machen kann
ein bisschen tipps kriege was ich noch
besser machen kann das ist mir auch
wichtig das feedback zu bekommen also
nicht nur von euch sondern danach
voneinander zweck und ja das finde ich
richtig geil
das sollte laufen und ja ich habe gar
nicht mehr so viel zeit ich habe in 24
minuten schon die nächste vorlesung
deswegen muss ich das ja relativ kurz
halten würde einfach sagen nehmt mir
nicht übel dass ich heute keinen video
wo man konnte also kein gameplay
whatever
deshalb kann ich nicht zocken weil ich
im echten leben hat keinen brach um habt
ihr mir hinterher rennt gab es in die
kommentare
wenn ich mal live video machen soll wo
ich meinen drachen weg gerne so jobmäßig
und ja dann würde ich sagen
haut rein leute macht es gut wir sehen
uns morgen wieder mit einem minecraft
video und